he's really passionate about what he
does so he's he's got a thousand ideas
you know so he's taking things bits and
people every now and then I'll try to
put something in his ear but he's taking
this thing uh by the horns and and is uh
writing it out on that that first
episode of that
uh show aired I think that's when you
saw the full formation coming to to home
this guy's changed what's going on here
the dean show combined with his passion
for jiu jitsu has made Eddie achieve
goals he never thought possible
Eddie's Purpose with the dean show was
to Enlighten people who might be in a
similar condition as he was in the past
it is good for him to back up for all
those uh times that he missed doing what
his rights so you know and he probably
realizes yeah that's why he's working
extra hard you know
and he continues his struggle to help
people find a way that has been lost to
them
for he himself is an example of
redemption
he is living proof that if one puts his
or her mind to it they can achieve
anything being part of the biggest
family of martial arts a little over a
few hundred students and the dean show
man man it's a lot of work he's a
machine if someone who knew Addie uh in
his youth they would maybe predict that
he'd be dead or he'd be in jail or he'd
be in the negative side of life you know
but to see someone change to see that
their their whole um their character
changes to see their uh these you know
countless change positive changes in
their life it's a sign of God
randomly selected twice
you'll see the five minutes three
minutes on the prompter
how do you choose your guests
the law chooses to guess I just pick him
up brother
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign
up in America
Eddie lived the American dream
he achieved it all before the age of 30.
money cars women but beneath the surface
something didn't feel right
after achieving everything he ever
desired
and he turned his back and walked away
from it all
and took his life in a whole new
Direction let us take you on his journey
[Music]
Eddie was born in Buffalo New York to
parents who had immigrated from
Yugoslavia in the early 1970s
soon after Eddie's birth
Eddie's Father decided to move to
Chicago in search of a better job
my wife she was working
I was working
I was working also nighttime during that
day you know on the weekend usually his
father comes late from that kind of a
work a kid was many times left on his
own was a sun vacuum there and he just
filled it up with uh undesirable friends
and with undesirable things I used to
also took him took him to nightclub
where I sing you know or you know
playing pool or during the daytime when
I free that time I
I don't know really that how to race you
know child we were more consumed with
what normal kids are consumed with just
having a good time
really just playing video games
getting out there on the streets and
trying to find something exciting
Adrenaline Rush growing up as a youth I
had a lot of
say we had a lot of maybe confusion from
his early years Eddie always found
himself in trouble
I wasn't the oldest one of the bunch but
I was willing always to go a step
further I would sometimes go and defend
those who I thought to be really my
brothers and those who are close to me
I was the one to step up and make sure
that nobody was going to mess with my
brothers my friends I remember one time
and they catch him and and some other
his friend you know and he was a kind of
leader growing up he
was I would say in his early years was
you know not too far from trouble
um but he was always at the same time
like a concerning brother even though he
was involved in a lot of trouble
he still would make sure that you know
me being younger would not you know make
those same mistakes he made usually uh
uh our children formed by their 15th
year you know and once it's a little bit
harder to form them later so during
those 15 years uh definitely there was
uh some lack of
proper up bringing you know you know
children out of like a garden you know
you water the garden you weed the garden
you know uh regularly and you miss it
one week and the garden is overtaken by
the weeds in a society that demanded
both parents to work children would be
the ones most affected
uh kids sometimes need more attention if
they don't get it at home because the
parents are busy working and I know his
parents were working a lot and then
he seems to me he needed more time to be
spent with him by his parents Society
taught Eddie to hone a tough idea of
manhood in elementary school you would
get in fights and you have one group of
kids kids fighting the other group of
kids so now you pick up on this and
that's that like Street mentality that
was not knowing the truth you know there
was just believing whatever he sees on
TV or reads in the paper so uh it was my
impression that's that's how he saw the
world you know in Chicago
going to high school here and you kind
of feel like to to prove your strength
and to be a ladies man to chase women
that's what most youth are talking about
and that's what your level of status is
he started having his problems you know
Disobedience towards parents gang
activity fights uh it was uh he was you
know kind of disturbed things were going
out of the control you know one fight
here another fight there trying to get
this person's attention school really
was secondary it was getting in class
just to wait for the Bell to ring
looking up at the time oh man this is
dragging on I hope this will end soon so
I can go and try to hook up with this
person or this crowd cut class uh they
are being bombarded by all uh from all
sides by uh things which are immoral
which are not good which are not right
on the TV on the internet on the street
newspapers there's so so much bad things
and negativity that children is soaking
up all those bad influences from outside
if the parent doesn't take time to
neutralize those their children don't
have a way of learning what is good what
is bad they just take the easy way and
pick up whatever is thrown at them as we
learn birds of a southern flock together
so I was going around along with the bad
company I end up getting what they call
violated and they put you up basically
beat you up for about you know a couple
minutes and now afterwards you're you're
in you've taken the beating and now
you're part of that clip that
organization that gang street gang the
false sense of Independence brainwashed
Eddie into living it rough and tough
gang life because the whole gang thing
the whole perception here is that this
is now my family you know I felt like I
belonged to something I belong to this
group I belong to what I thought now was
my fam which I had my my family at home
who really cared about me and they
wanted what's what's best for me not
with these people they didn't care about
me misery loves companies so I'm going
through life running away from home and
my mother she was going out of her mind
trying to find me and she drove up one
time into the
school where we would hang out and we're
in this little Courtyard and she drives
up this is the only place where like the
police would drive up but she she drove
up in here and I we thought it was the
police so now I'm running from the
police I'm running from my parents I'm
running here running there I'm running
everywhere but mainly I'm running the
wrong way gang life took hold of Eddie
and forced him to travel a negative and
destructive path
going from one high school to the next I
had to leave that Lincoln Park because
it was an opposing gang so now if they
find out that I'm in this gang I mean
that's the whole school is associated
with that gang so I got to get out of
that school now I end up getting
transferred to another school and I
remember one time when I was in the
cafeteria and this
gangbanger of the opposite gang he came
and he threw down my gang sign so that
was the wrong thing to do and then this
is something silly that you're ready to
kill the person over some stupid hand
gesture
so he does that and I throw his down
he ends up pulling a knife I end up
pulling some mace I spray him and from
there all the different security guards
came at the school we get taken in
to the
disciplinary
office and I'm expelled finally I
started figuring out that these people
didn't care about me these gang bangers
when you're sitting in a jail cell and
they catch you for some kind of stupid
crime some of these people the police
show you who the head guys are and
they've been arrested for murder and all
sorts of drug trafficking these are the
higher ones that are basically pimping
the young guys I said I'm sitting in a
jail cell and where are they at nobody's
coming to get me they don't care about
me and am I going to end up with a mug
shot like this and I'm going to end up
tomorrow killing somebody because that's
what it's heading to I mean they're
going to get killed or I'm going to kill
somebody I'm going to end up in jail
destroying my life I have a good family
it's not worth it I ended up going to
Germany I thought this would be a good
break he disappeared you know he took
off we went to different places in
Chicago where we thought he could be to
find him you know and we couldn't find
him that day my brother-in-law from
Germany I have a sister in Germany
he called us he says are you okay you
you let let Eddie come over here
says no after spending time in Germany
Eddie realized his life was not leading
anywhere he finally returned to Chicago
only this time it was not to the gangs
big cash money was on Eddie's mind
how to make money so the direction I'm
getting from is from movies from actors
from the gangsters on the big screen and
I can relate to them you know everyone
needs a role model and I thought that
these the rappers the musicians the
actors I'm starting to see other people
imitate them so I feel you know what I
can portray this role quite well he
gradually worked his way up in the club
industry but money or not it still
brought trouble one night's policeman
called me from the station so you'll at
least father yes come on get him from
the station he's locked up I went over
there
anyone
also individual working to from from the
station all of blood everything you know
I just went straight to the to the desk
and I was worried what happened Eddie
and this officer he said this officer he
says
he read his father Yes do you see this
the person just walked out
that's what your son done to him
fearing that Eddie would get into deeper
trouble or worse
his father convinced Eddie to enlist
with him in the U.S army as a civil
interpreter in war-torn Bosnia
after I had been in Bosnia working with
the military for some time I hooked up
with individual that I inspired to be
like when you watch some of the other
Goodfellas and you hear about Al Capone
this individual was the closest
resemblance to those people and I wanted
to be the top of that lifestyle and he
took great care of me he took me into
his home his many homes he showed me
around and said pick one and I saw the
lifestyle he had that country basically
it was his and he was someone who was
who you didn't want to cross and he was
respected
and I took to him and we were very close
Eddie returned to Chicago from Bosnia
with a new understanding of the world in
the same way he demanded respect
and loyalty this is something that I
demanded and if I didn't get then I took
and I put fear in people the same way he
was doing
influenced by his father's work in the
club industry Eddie naturally began to
seek out that path we worked for uh for
one of the largest promoters in Chicago
and he worked for him and I worked for
him as well and he was one of the guys
one of the enforcers he used to run
around basically just beat up people
that was really at his nature and his
Essence he was also a ladies man and he
brought in a lot of the ladies at any
given moment he could have seven to
eight women that are running around the
club looking for him while all of this
was happening
Eddie who loved to fight found a new
form of release in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I
had boxed did some boxing as a teen and
from there I had tried different martial
arts
what I really got fascinated with was
the the
rationale and logic that hit me when I
saw Gracie Brazilian Jitsu that really
went a 120 130 pound guy around that he
put me it was called the submission arm
lock and I was so gassed and I was just
about back then working out because it
was the mentality you know the more you
can bench press the more you know you
were stronger and physically able to
push people around and along with the
boxing and that that was a good
combination but once Jiu Jitsu that took
hold this was something that was really
captivating and I just took it to a
whole other level you know there's 24
hours in a day but it seemed like for 25
hours he was training you know he was
researching training sparring just you
know was in love with it Jiu Jitsu you
know change him you know and I saw that
it wasn't always about Bruce strength
that there was a different way to
approach it and that was a totally
different experience the Jiu Jitsu I
really start to get involved in this
because it fascinated me it was
practical it it worked I started to
train in the Jiu Jitsu I became the
person who was out here the instructor I
became his top student but Jiu Jitsu
wasn't enough to keep Eddie away from
the cooler lifestyle
the worldly side some are looking in
you've got it made but there's something
missing inside one minute happy because
there's some pleasure that happens in my
life maybe I make some money maybe I
hook up with a certain young lady really
just again marking time marking time I
know Eddie's presence was very
significant in the club everybody knew
Eddie from the outside people looking in
and said hey this is the man Pauline he
was dating one of the hottest girls in
the city he decided to get a uh get a
Harley a chopper 4 30 a nice new
Mercedes oh he's got the nice car he's
got the people who are flocking to be
around him they want to be on that guest
list you live in a dream but at the end
when you go through this cycle again you
just it's more corruption you're around
people who are just cut throat
dirty business people liars and I had
learned better values for my family as
the cool became common
Eddie began to have a new sense of life
we're about six months into uh owning
this nightclub together we were probably
drinking six nights a week because we're
at the bar all the time so as training
went down about women went up and Eddie
I think to this day may look at God's
way of kind of saying yeah you're having
fun but this isn't the way you're
supposed to be having fun all the power
he possessed still made him feel
helpless
foreign
Eddie once beat up his best friend who
tried to steal Eddie's girlfriend
I don't think he felt any better about
himself his ego may have felt better but
his inner soul didn't feel better his
inner soul was broken at that moment he
started to realize that as strong as he
is and as intimidating as he is as an
individual
it really didn't matter there was no
peace the overall entertainment around
me it had me hypnotized until situations
got heated like a big big fight we had
one of the guys a few of them really got
hurt one guy almost died and next thing
you know at three in the morning the
following night I'm getting knocked on
the door the detectives are there and
I'm in the bullpen and in the county
jail and I'm praying earnestly well God
help me oh God help me get me out of
here I don't want to be in jail
everything let me just get out and kiss
the ground nobody wants to be there the
Glamorous Life Eddie had been living
felt shallow and empty there was no
peace of mind initially when we met it's
Eddie seemed pretty perfect the perfect
lifestyle all the women all the cars a
tough guy he can do anything he wants to
do runs around with his head up but as I
got to know him it seemed it seemed
flawed there was things missing his
physical being was great for his ego but
it left him empty I kept it always real
I said if I do make a million I'll be
the same guy
I might have a bigger house maybe a
nicer car but what then right near the
end there was just a void and I started
to look at some of the celebrities lives
I would go through talking to some of
these people and man these people are
more depressed than the average Joe
feeling lost
Eddie started searching for answers I
sincerely wanted to know what was my
purpose in life
it didn't take long before Eddie was
reminded of death one time from coming
after an after party we had like maybe a
half a dozen of us stuck in an elevator
and I started to think about that moment
when we were stuck in the elevator
everybody's just cramped together and I
was like wow this is scary the incident
shook Eddie up
this was the reality it was death and it
scared me because I knew that one day I
would be in the grave I would be in the
grave there is no and if buts no one can
differ about this we can all agree we
are going to die and their entertainment
around us is just having us not reflect
over this I started to read books I was
like a sponge I just kept taking in
everything I took in it just required
effort it required sincerity wanting it
first because if you're not in the
market
if you're not in the market then that's
a different story doesn't matter what
comes to you you're not going to be
interested but I was a in the market and
I was sincere and who bet better to tell
me than the one who created me this life
is a test it's short and we have to be
in a constant state of self-development
to develop ourselves to be the best
human beings and I couldn't do it on my
own whims and desires so I started to
familiarize myself I started to look
into different religions because I
wanted to see hold on what about all the
religions out there there's a lot of
them so let me see now let me have an
open mind let me be not non-biased and
look into the different ways
that are claiming that they're the truth
I was in Brazil I was maybe a week from
coming home and I was talking to my
brother on the phone and then he asked
me a question on Islam like did you read
this book he wanted to make sure himself
and inside his heart that that was the
truth the more I looked into it the more
I saw that Islam didn't promote
terrorism that Islam didn't oppress
women that Islam was free from all these
lies that were just people backbiting
the same way they back bite out there
against individuals they were basically
talking out of ignorance not knowing and
then I felt compelled to talk with
people when my brother first started to
learn Islam he was so enthusiastic that
he was always been stubborn
believing that his way was the right way
and so I think by him embracing that and
understanding it and by arming himself
with all the knowledge he can he became
a very lethal individual in his aspect
of his religion he did in the beginning
in the weight room talking really loud
and things like that but we shortly
found out after people get can be
offended people can have the wrong
impression he started to talk a lot more
about religion more barriers came up
because I don't think I was there where
he was at that moment in time there were
so many things he was struggling with he
was struggling with religion trying to
change his ways not drinking anymore
even after I learned I can't change
people's hearts at least I can share
this message and try to clear the
negative stereotypes people actually
started talking behind his back look at
him he's trying to be a good guy it was
not as easy as Eddie thought it would be
I had been reading more and just really
thought that if I just share this with
the people that I knew that they will
come to the same realization they would
come to the same conclusion you know
that I came to that this is indeed the
truth and the more I shared it with
people it would be funny because I'd get
silly arguments people just out of
ignorance some people they really
wouldn't even you know consider it it
was just thinking as they're listening
how I can refute this and giving all the
different proofs that I had found it
really you know for the people that I
was talking to it wasn't really moving
them whatsoever it had an impact on me I
was depressed because these people that
they love to listen to me talk about
everything else but when I started to
talk about more serious things hey guys
look you know what's the purpose of life
people were were just stubbornly
resistant and I started looking at you
like here you know from outer space and
then I opened up the Quran and in in
Surah too
verse 6 as I run from the beginning this
is a book where there's no doubt I
realize that I'm not in control of the
hearts of the people
it was the one who is the creator he's
in control of the hearts it wasn't about
forcing people to change I did my job I
shared what I knew this new information
you know maybe God Almighty will guide
them at a different time maybe at one
point they'll realize and go through
some of the things that I went through
to get here Eddie's newly acquired
knowledge allowed him to see life in a
very different way
now the transition didn't happen
overnight it's not like now you find the
truth and all of a sudden you're just
free from all the different vices that
you've had it was a constant struggle I
gave up drinking right away I didn't I
never smoke but there was other vices
that took time for me to get rid of out
of my life when I was in these places it
was funny that I was giving people doubt
I was talking about something and it was
it was different to be in these these
places and you see everybody's drunk
everybody's out of their mind so he
started less and less going to the club
he'll go to his parties but leave like
be there for an hour and leave
or sometimes he wouldn't even show up
and just have uh me and someone else run
it he kind of like wanted to talk to
people about Islam but then he was kind
of being a hypocrite because he was in
the scene and I think it forced him more
to get out of it I didn't give up the
prayer I would hide somewhere to make it
if I couldn't make it in the club I
would walk out of the club
and I would go and make it in the car I
did not give up that prayer that was
something that I feel it saved me Eddie
had stopped drinking at this point Nina
used to drink a lot at Eastern maybe
more than me at that point Eddie had
quit drinking the silver two three month
time period he was praying five times a
day he was uh doing a lot of reading a
lot of studying on Islam giving up the
old lifestyle proved to be a real
struggle for Eddie but determined as he
was he quickly adapted to the situation
and he was able to initially separate
the two it was like a switch he was able
to come into Butterfield eight the
nightclub we promote every Saturday and
be a different person maybe he would
slip he would have a drink but then he
would leave and it was like he would he
would shut the switch off so now he
would go and he would start he would
listen to a lot of documentaries he
would go read the Quran he would do uh
he would pray he was Dr Jekyll Mr Hyde
and he was struggling with that but the
effort was there there was a conscious
effort to make that switch once Eddie
myself parted ways and we stopped doing
events together that's where Eddie was
able to separate himself completely from
The Nightlife the nightclub environment
Eddie felt imprisoned by everything that
was surrounding him I have to get out of
this
totally and the more I learn and the
more I implemented the easier it became
for me to start to transition to leave
off a lot of the old friends I was to
get away from Chicago you need to get
out
so he came down here visited I know one
night uh his last night here in Windsor
he was staying at the casino I think it
was a conscious effort on his part to
try to hit rock bottom he did things
things that he uh he pushed himself to
the to the ethical extremes that he
could to do things that to this day I
think played play played in an integral
role in helping him evolve into the
person he is I remember seeing him the
next day before he left and there was
that emptiness in his eyes there was a
bigger emptiness that I think I've ever
really seen in his eyes Jiu Jitsu
provided a way out for Eddie I want to
thank God also for jiu jitsu because Jiu
Jitsu also helped me to
spend more time doing something
constructive something that's fun and
and it helped me also to channel some of
my energy into something positive and
it's it's a struggle like life itself is
a struggle you to get better you have to
be more disciplined to achieve the
different belt levels you have to stay
with it you cannot give up working out
you cannot give up you see the benefits
at the end the martial arts have a a
very strong history in
um etiquette and mannerisms and things
that uh that a way a culture a way to
live that's outside of fighting you know
like having respect being humble things
like that so
um when we before we were black belts
and before we were practicing Islam we
were like the complete opposite when you
sign up for a membership at a health
club or at Jiu Jitsu or anywhere there
needs to be some f effort you get
excited now you say okay I need this is
what I need in my life I need to lose
weight now you get in there and you sign
up but after two three classes you're
just lazy I mean you just don't want to
continue forward and now you only hinder
yourself now you're not going to
accomplish that great feeling of feeling
good looking good being healthy it's
going to require some work it's the same
thing here it's the same thing with this
way of life that the creator has laid
down for all of us to live it's a way to
develop yourself to be a better human
being so you're going to have to
sacrifice you're going to have to be
disciplined there's some things that you
might have to give up but if you are
sincere and you earnestly want it you're
going to see that these things weren't
even good for me in the first place
[Music]
these are material
this universe and everything in
it that design
designer
we don't like that
we can understand it but when people
they go and they direct what's supposed
to be directed to the Creator they
direct it to someone else
you give me a hundred dollars instead of
saying thank you yeah I say thank you to
someone else
[Music]
so it should be directed to the one
who's giving you the eyes the ears your
life will give you left
not to his messenger Saints Idols icons
to him
but of course if he trained me I should
say thank you thank you from the streets
Embrace with a hug and creepy whistle
I'm
a Muslim I came from the streets to
Islam they get old now when you see your
brother give a bomb Embrace with a hug
angry whistle I'm celebrating certain
things
[Music]
my first trap have my adversary my first
with big ribs when I push that my first
time locked in pen it would never end
they would release me a roll with fears
rushing off my pain then I end up
working again what's the spin
[Music]
wow
going to a high school to talk to some
faculty there answer to some students
um
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm very excited to talk to the
non-muslims our brothers and Humanity we
have three types of Brothers you have
your blood brothers
then you have those Brothers in humanity
of when you hear Islam and you hear
something blowing up you right away
attribute a lot of times people
attribute and oh this is another Muslim
and now it's another event that's
attributed to assumption Islam peace
acquired by submitting your will to the
will of the Creator so you'll be getting
God willing some of these
DVDs which I have some of the guests
that come on Scholars they come on the
show and we help tackle many of the
subjects that are on the minds of the
people thank you for coming Kevin nice
to meet you are you uh yeah yeah
[Music]
peace be unto you welcome to the dean
show which is a way of life we try to
put out there for everyone to see
helping you understand Islam and Muslims
uh when he started the dean show
it was just an idea I was on my way I
was about to do the fifth pillar of
Islam I believe he was going to Hajj at
the time with my good friend so they
wanted to make sure that they did all
the Hajj requirements you know that they
fulfilled their Hajj and there was a lot
of different technical things that I had
to remember
the ins and outs what I couldn't do
could do so they decided to uh ask an
Islamic scholar random questions and
tape it and we wanted to make it more
interactive where it wasn't just a
person giving a lecture it was someone
that we can interact with and make it
fun and we did that and from there it
turned out great and then it spun off to
another topic to another topic it
actually began with a regular cheap
camera only four or five hundred dollar
camera and uh it was one angle and we'll
kind of zoom in the camera the tripod
would shake or we were having our hands
and I was trying to record and too much
wiggling and Betty's concept was he
wanted to start showing his slime and
spread it to the non-muslims he just
fully wanted to
um
have other people experience what he's
going through he kind of was like why
are we doing this no one's going to take
you serious but Eddie wasn't going to
take no for an answer I said with Eddie
Eddie once you start something he goes
100 so he wanted to do it so what he did
he didn't want to talk he took a camera
didn't matter what camera it was and
started recording because he knows if
you don't start you're never going to
get nowhere you know he had to start
somewhere it wasn't always that easy I
had to be out there struggling like
anybody in any field that they want to
grow I have to be out there putting the
work I had to approach people people
didn't know who I was and I had to be
out there and trying to convince people
to be on the show when he first started
off when no one didn't know who he was
he was trying to get some in contact
with some of the bigger shakes and they
didn't want to he was frustrated that
someone that didn't want to talk because
they want to show her the video was
going to go I had to fly myself to
different places to try to get people I
had to if I met someone who I was going
to bring on have to pay for them to come
out and it took a lot of work you know
since 2006 we started and now we're on
the local cable station in Chicago we're
also on another station that reaches
Canada and the US and working to have it
in UK on some satellite stations there
you working out
okay just want to make sure you're ready
for filming tonight
yeah
so
God willing inshallah
pick up
the
and then we're gonna
go back to the studio
and
throw some shows and Shop
how do you choose your guests
the law chooses to guess I just pick him
up brother
[Laughter]
you have a lot of people that are just
angry they haven't figured out why
they're here in life nor are they
seeking the truth so they're just bitter
they're not trying to get involved with
all the drama we're trying to live a
nice peaceful life
okay
yes
I randomly selected twice
we wanted to talk about music a little
bit because
um
you'll see the five minutes three
minutes on the prompter okay okay you'll
see it's red once you started recording
here
are you wrapping up Bill
you get the chance to watch the showboat
yeah it makes sense huh did it make
sense yeah
[Music]
the website we mentioned you go see some
more of the shows that we did yeah
they educate educational
you know that's why I watch it
all right guys all right okay all right
and I like your setting too oh thank you
you improve a lot you know oh yeah yeah
thank you take care of yourself
[Applause]
he's really passionate about what he
does so he's he's got a thousand ideas
you know so he's taking things bits and
every now and then I'll try to put
something in his ear but he's taking
this thing uh by the horns and is uh
writing it up on that that first episode
of that
uh show aired I think that's when you
saw the full formation come into to home
this guy's changed what's going on here
the dean show combined with his passion
for jiu jitsu
has made Eddie achieve goals he never
thought possible
Eddie's Purpose with the dean show was
to Enlighten people who might be in a
similar condition as he was in the past
it is good for him to make up for all
those uh times that he missed doing what
is right so you know and he probably
realizes that that's why he's working
extra hard you know
and he continues his struggle to help
people find a way that has been lost to
them
for he himself is an example of
redemption
he is living proof that if one puts his
or her mind to it they can achieve
anything if you want to do it and you
have a willpower you can do it and if
you if you have uh some support and some
guidance it is possible being part of
the biggest family of martial arts a
little over a few hundred students
having a family having three kids right
now and the dean show man man it's a lot
of work he's a machine you know if
someone who knew Eddie and his youth
they would maybe predict that he'd be
dead or he'd be in jail or he'd be
definitely and
under a negative side of life you know
but to see someone change to see that
their their whole um their character
changes to see their uh these you know
countless change it positive changes in
their life it's a sign of God
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I expect them to know after what they've
been told what you're trying to achieve
bro from that life on the road is time
[Music]
yes yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
gotta get the keys
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened and basically
is far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is needed for the whole stick
because we don't have anything like that
in the whole state that was sensor where
it's gonna basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam
birthday